let's talk a little bit about bitcoin
and politics um obviously there seems to
be a sentiment change uh first it
started on kind of the right side of the
aisle it looks now like a lot of
democrats also are becoming more pro
bitcoin pro crypto
how important is it for a politician at
this point to understand these
technologies and
is it fair to say that over the next
couple of years if you're anti this
technology you're probably either going
to get voted out or not elected
so i think the most important
week
in lots of ways in crypto last year was
around the infrastructure bill
when
the biden administration really tried to
sneak in
a poison pill or at least you know a get
you sick pill
uh into that legislation
and
the crypto community mobilized uh
i
remember i was in the south of france on
vacation my only vacation i took and i
was on the phone with every senator i
knew but everyone was
more impressively there was this retail
groundswell there were millions
of phone calls placed to congressmen and
senators and dc was shocked
uh that was the wake up call when they
realized
this is a really powerful voting block
and it's often a single issue voting
block
don't screw with my bitcoin
don't screw with my crypt though
uh
you know elizabeth warren who has got a
lot of
clout
with the biden administration
who is very close to the the head of the
sec
had a lot of influence
about how the body demonstration was
thinking
and
what is really interesting is janet
yellen
and the and the president's
uh order
really had a change in tone recently
uh it was a change in tone for being
negative to being balanced
that's politics that is not because they
saw the light it's because they like wow
we need to pay attention and there are
two things that got them thinking
right
this is about innovation
right and it's about the little guy
uh
and so
i think that narrative is changing in dc
i don't see legislation showing up this
year the way politics are set up we're
going to be in a gridlock
but i think the chance of them doing
really damaging things has gone away
down
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time